lunchtime at the high field in
edgeboston
but tier three restrictions in
birmingham mean it's takeaway only
and the restaurant remains closed now a
pilot project has been proposed
that would allow indoor dining within
hours of a negative covid test
we think it's brilliant um i mean our
main focus since
we've reached the pandemic has been
keeping people safe
and that's our will always be our core
value and if this can help us
get our guests back safely then we're
100 behind it
the test and dying pilot has been put
forward by birmingham city council
it would initially involve a small
number of restaurants
people would book a table get tested and
if the result was negative head out to
eat
as long as the booking had been made
within six hours of that test
the plan would then be to expand the
idea to other areas
we desperately need to be doing more to
help all of these sectors
hospitality arts and events all three of
which
have really struggled over the last nine
months uh they need
more support from the government and
this is an innovative way in which we
could help these sectors
it wouldn't cost the government any more
than they're already spending and it may
open up a solution not only here in
birmingham but across the rest of the
country
a craft in the city the doors remain
closed
but the owners concerned the proposed
route to reopening
would be too big a risk if a business
was expecting 100 guests to arrive and
then subsequently as a result of testing
only had half of those guests arrive the
the cost around the wastage of stock
and additional manpower would be
significant
and i'm also concerned that our staff
would start to
sway into some sort of enforcement
capacity
there have also been questions about the
accuracy of rapid testing if the science
works and the test work i think it's a
really important thing to try to get
hospitality moving again but first and
foremost it needs to be proven that
it's safe to do so because we don't want
another
another wave of infections i think it's
worth investigating i think that if we
could do anything to support the
local businesses which have been really
hit we've been in tier three locked down
for months and months and months
no decisions being made by the
government about whether to proceed with
the pilot
but it's providing a glimmer of hope for
restaurants like this
so desperate to get back in business
emma birchley sky news birmingham